trepidation
about the long-term effects of these
novel vaccines seems disproportionate is
this just based on the precautionary
principle
um yes and no i would say i don't think
it's disproportionate
obviously i guess this person is
commenting on our trepidations
i think so i don't think our disp our
trepidations are disproportionate
obviously
they'd be smaller but i think the point
is once you have
seen what complex adaptive systems are
like and how difficult it is to predict
what is going to happen
and then you see oh no we've got a
complex system
within a complex system within a complex
system so yeah to spell that out
you've got the population level what are
the dynamics of the virus and the
immunity
in the population you've got the
individual oh my god that's a biological
complex system
in which it is effectively going to be
impossible to know what a novel
phenomenon is going to do
when introduced into that body we have
to find out empirically
and the duration over which we'd have to
look is extremely long
and then oh my god on top of that you've
got this thing is
interacting with the immune system which
is actually the one system in the body
that literally evolves
within the scale of weeks to months
the point is that level of complexity
interfacing with each other
guarantees that there will be phenomena
here you simply cannot predict
especially given our very early stage
and even understanding the way these
things work
so what are the chances that there's
going to be bad stuff
it's higher than you think i don't want
to say that i want to be a cheerleader
for vaccines because we're so good at
wielding them and we're so wise about
what kind of harm they're going to do
but i know we're not right
so um three complex systems three
complex adaptive systems
layered on top of each other where one
of them is the immune system and when it
goes wrong
it's liable to be to create an
autoimmunity
uh or a cancer or something like that
that's a lot of hazard yeah
in such a situation we prefer tried and
true yes and
even then even then our point has not
been don't do this our point is you've
got
competing bad situations you've got
covid on the one hand which is worse
than people
think and you've got the vaccines which
are less well understood than we are
pretending and
those two things now you know this is
the situation you don't want to be in
where you have to make a decision that
you know you don't have any good answers
[Music]
you